So the sequence that would probably give us the
most severe change is the second one. And the reason
is because TGA codes for a stop codon. A stop
codon means we would produce this amino acid, methionine, then
valine. And then we'd stop. And we wouldn't get anything
else for the rest of the sequence. That is going
to drastically alter the overall protein. Now, the next most
severe change would be the first one. Because it changes
the amino acid to just something else. GCG
codes for alanine instead of valine. Sure, it's a
change. It could possibly be bad. But, it's not
as bad as a stop codon, which eliminates all
the rest of the amino acids. And then this
last sequence here would be the least sever, most
likely because GTA is a change from GTG, and
if we use the genetic code, we see that
it doesn't change the amino acid at all. We still got a Valine.